[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce soir c'est la race
charolaise que nous mettrons à l'honneur
dans notre page elles ont pris la place
des simard d'aller des montbéliard les
races laitières sont partis c'était la
rotation c'était cette nuit regardez
c'était impressionnant
19 heures la nuit tombe sur paris les
visiteurs qui progressivement le salon
remplacé par le ballet des camions
car ce soir c'est la grande rotation des
animaux les vaches laitières vont
laisser la place aux races à viande
après cinq jours de salon animaux comme
éleveurs ne sont sains et content de
rentrer
cd paru en a passé cinq jours ici on est
bien content de venir mais aussi on est
bien content de repartir c'est quand
même assez fatigant
[Musique]
pour ces montbéliarde ces retours en
haute saône les bêtes de concours
repartent chargé de médailles quant à
florine ce premier voyage à paris
restera pour toujours gravé dans sa
mémoire
meilleur souvenir c'est quoi c'est de
passer sur le ring avec ma vache sa
fierté dans une vache à la capitale
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait alors fait
venir mais c'est pas gentil c'est
participer déjà d'arriver jusqu'ici
c'est déjà d'une belle épreuve épaules à
peine les animaux parti que l'équipe de
nettoyage entre en action
ce soir ils ne seront pas trop de 30 car
les charolaises attendent déjà vos
consultants sont nécessaires à tout va
bien
parti à 15 heures de charolles les 14
bet de serge commence à s'impatienter on
est fier d'expliquer notre métier ou la
fièvre de les présenter notation
on est fier de représenter nos classes
l'aberration
il est près de minuit 30
place au dîner
après une bonne nuit confortablement
installés les charolais seront prêts à
prendre la relève
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était la journée bourgogne
franche comté sur le salon de
l'agriculture
l'occasion pour la présidente de région
et les différends politiques de venir à
la rencontre des producteurs et des
éleveurs
cette année la région a choisi de
sensibiliser les visiteurs à
l'importance du manger local et du bien
manger en plus des stands des
producteurs locaux les produits du
terroir sont proposés à la dégustation
ou à la vente au bistro de la région qui
réitère cette année encore son bar à
main et son bar à fromage pour séduire
les parisiens
[Musique]
où
au menu de notre escapade dans paris
aujourd'hui le restaurant ma salle du
nom d'une technique de sélection des
plants de vigne ici on ne sert que des
vins naturels de l'est de la france
dans sa cave thomas chapelle garde des
crus qu'il a lui-même sélectionnés dans
chaque domaine
c'est la réserve
[Musique]
donc là on est sur une parcelle de
poussard 100%
qui est pleine de fraîcheur dans la
finesse c'est un gars qui est bien
terminée bien finie va un peu de
bourgogne aussi ça c'est un domaine qui
ont trait beaucoup show dont brillent à
savigny-lès-beaune ses 17 hectares en
bio dynamie ça c'est bien ça
c'est un savagnin houllier 2016 les
chassagne de chez philippe bernard tony
bornard maintenant c'est super ça vu
bien pouvoir goûter sa
malle expression de la minéralité
jurassienne avec les les terroirs de
marne qui donne des armes des arômes un
petit peu citronnée sur des baux amer
c'est très jurassien voilà c'est
vraiment un vin jurassien comme on dit
ce sont des vins naturels ça vient ce
sont des bras qui ne reçoivent pas de
traitement ni dans la vie ni dans la
cuve tout simplement
en salle antonin dole et prend le relais
pour soumettre les vins jurassiens aux
clients
jours mais ce monsieur est déjà connaît
ça
j'aime bien les
vins peu moins
d'un côté pour moi
moins connue donc les petites
productions du jura sa matière depuis
depuis longtemps mon permis en
consommaient aussi donc ça fait
longtemps que j'en fais pas mal la pub
parce que j'aime bien
thomas chapelle aime aussi proposé même
enfant de repasser dernières découvertes
aux habitués alors messieurs alors vous
aviez commandé aujourd'hui un plus tard
du jura à
2016 d'un degryse d'avant je trouve vous
voyez une couleur assez assez étrange
jamais assez mais tout ça avant très bon
effectivement c'est les vins qui sont
banques courent en effet fréquent qu'on
découvre ici il transmet quelque chose
qu'on a forcément
[Musique]
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui demain de
par le monde et champ suivant notamment
pour des griffons nivernais puis nous et
moi rungis le plus grand marché de
france voir les produits carnés de notre
région qui nourrissent la capitale bonne
soirée à demain
[Musique]